Này từ sang sở Mỹ chình Ảng một, lực lượng chức năng của mừng cảnh xa rau thuồng, cảnh xa cơ động,
công man phương phủ học của mừng lực lượng con đổi, là các chốt kìm soát tại các tiến đường chọt yếu
giấn về chúng tâm hội nghi Quốc gia. Phân loồng, điều tiết giao thông, hướng giấn phương tiện
liền thông an toàn trên các tiến đường giận đến khu vực tủ chức này hội và các tiến đường
chọt liền xung quanh. Mọi biến đậu rao thông được theo dõi, phân tích linh tục của quai hệ thống
và đỏ kịp thời điều chính phương án, sử lý tình hủng phát xinh.
Nhờ đầy mạnh công tắc tiến chuyển thông tin kịp thời về phương án tổ chức răng thông,
các tính nồng cấm, hạn chế lưng thông, người dân thủ đấu chủ động phối hợp
lựa trọt lộ trình thái thế, các đơn vị trình khai nhệm vụ theo phương trân,
gió người, gió việc, gió nhệm vụ, gió thời gian, gió triển nhệm, bảo đảm anh ninh,
anh toàn ở mức cao nhất nhưng không mạnh hưởng đến sinh hoạt đi lại bình thường của người dân.
Tâm cường phối hợp, giúp đồng chả trẻ gió kháng người lựa không đề phát xinh tình hủng phức tạp, giù là nhỏ nhớt.